präsident danke dass sie uns hier in
warschau willkommen heißen als ich im
januar in kiew hat niemand erwartet dass
putin auch kiew angreifen wird alle
haben nur über den osten diskutiert
jetzt sitzen wir in warschau denken sie
dass putin auch warschauer auch den
präsidentenpalast attackieren könnte
georgen angriff war der damalige
polnische präsident lech kaczynski das
minister ich war ich war mit arbeit sind
die präsidentschaftskanzlei wär echt
zusammen mit den präsidenten der
baltischen staaten ehemaligen
ukrainischen präsident nachdem sie
geflogen in der zeit als die russische
invasion schon andauerte und die
russischen truppen sich auf die wiese
hin bewegten die stand auf der
hauptstraße der polnische präsident
hielt eine rede und sagte
damals ihr eine stimme prophezeiung
klang und sie sind auch für europa sagte
dass der russische im preis muss wieder
aufgewacht sei und wie ein gesicht
russland
nicht mehr gesehen hätten dass wir
kennen würden eben das gesicht eines
imperialistischen staates der anderen
ihre freiheit weg und was man das auf
alle fälle anhalten müssen dass das
heute die pflicht der eu und ganzen welt
denn heute kommt georgien morgen
vielleicht die ukraine dann die
baltischen länder und land vielleicht
mein land buch sagte er damals das war
august 2008 und wir haben diese worte
immer sehr ernst genommen und wir waren
immer der meinung dass es in diesen
worten eine traurige und schreckliche
wahrheit gibt sind wir kennen die
russische imperialismus wird befanden
uns hunde 23 jahre lang
russische besatzung
hatten kurz unsere unabhängigkeit wurden
gleich von der sowjetunion überfallen
aber es gelang uns in einer schlacht
viele zurückzudrängen und
1939 griff zuerst hitler mit seinen
truppen
holen an und dann
wurde polen auch von der sowjetunion
angegriffen wurde zerrissen und in
beiden besagten es begann die leute und
die sowjetische besatzung wir befanden
uns dadurch eisernen vorhang in den
letzten 40 jahren unter dem einfluss des
sowjetischen
mit einer regierung die von russland
diktiert wurde ohne echte demokratie
ohne eine ehrliche regierung
wir wissen was sie bedeuten kann kann
und wir wissen das ist der
moment in dem die ukraine und tieren
angegriffen wurden erneut denn die frage
ist ja bereits 2014 angegriffen worden
das muss man offen sagen das waren keine
separatisten sind es war russland das
die ukraine
und die krim angegriffen da hatte europa
leide nicht adäquat reagiert und die
welt auch nicht auf diese situation aber
jetzt
vor über einhundert
die ukraine wieder angegriffen oder hier
fällt jedoch erwartet hatte obwohl ich
sagen muss ich hatte nicht erwartet das
ist einleuchtend
dass
russland einen angriff gegen
lugano für wahrscheinlich ich dachte sie
würden sich einen weg auf die krim
aber ich hatte nicht erwartet dass sie
angreifen obwohl ich wusste das ist
schon eine potenzielle potentes
angriffsziel wenn kiew hat eine
besondere bedeutung für russland das ist
die wiege dass sich hier virus
ist ein großes symbol des reichen
terroristischen russland offen gegenüber
der welt um eines russlands des einteile
welt regiert das sind also zwei sehr
wichtige symbole für russland für putin
wer dieses terroristische imperium maßen
manche sagen auch sowjetische imperium
wieder aufbauen will das große russland
braucht er aber
ich hatte ich daran geglaubt dass er
greifen könnte er tat es die russischen
truppen stand vor kiel fällt ihm nicht
markiert so kommen aber ich habe gesehen
was sie bei gf getan hatten mitte april
war ich bediene präsidenten der
bayerischen straßen in kiel kurz nachdem
sich die russen auf diesen gebieten
zurückgezogen hatten wir war den
produzieren kann gewannen in libyen wir
haben fürchterliche zerstörung
gesehen und
die enorm greul
wurden
auf die rücksichtslosigkeit mit
russland seine kriegsstrategie
generalisiert und dann gibt es keine
zweifel daran werde angreifen will sich
verteidiger für uns polen die sache klar
wir müssen alles tun um das imperiale
russland anzuhalten weil wir müssen ihn
und keinen auf alle möglichen weißen
helfen unsere größte hoffnung und auch
die baltischen staaten ist dass der
russische
imperialismus sich an der ukraine die
zähne ausbricht angehalten worden in der
zwischenzeit wir uns dann so bewaffnen
dass sie uns nicht mehr
angreifen
wie hoch schätzen sie die gefahr für
polen im moment ein
diese befürchtung gibt es die ganze zeit
aber zum erstaunen der ganzen welt
konnten die ukraine die natürlich hilfe
aus dem westen bekommen haben aber das
ist nicht so eine hilfe wo man eindeutig
sagen könnte sie haben eine hilfe
bekommt es sofort gewinnen würden wir
wissen wie das verhältnis ist eine
russischen und ukrainischen armee ist
man dachte am anfang und alle sagten
dass die russische armee die ukraine
einfach zermahlen wird das alles ohne
einen schuss stadt würde als stellte
sich aber heraus dass sie sich geirrt
haben wollen die mitte lady hatte mir
das gesagt wird unser treffen dass wenn
putin und die russen denken dass sie
einfach in der ukraine einmarschieren
und es beherrschen dann irren sie sich
wenn die ukraine kämpft seit acht jahren
in lukas und es gibt tausende von
menschen die an der front waren die
geschossen haben blut gesehen haben die
den tod ihre freunde gesehen haben
manche waren verwundert sie haben großen
mut und großes heldentum gezeigt aber
sie kennt den krieg und der ukraine hat
heute soldaten die um die ukraine
kämpfen können und die das auch bis zu
ihrem tod machen werden das hat mir war
zwei mal wiederholt ende januar besuchte
er mich in polen in wismar wir haben
lange miteinander gesprochen das war ein
informelle besuch eben um über alle
probleme zu sprechen die sowohl in den
polnisch ukrainischen beziehungen gibt
als auch an die buch über die globalen
probleme und später als ich einen tag
vor der russischen invasion zusammen mit
dem litauischen präsidentin in ein paar
stunden vor der russischen invasion
wiederholte andré bewerten und bis zum
umfallen verteidigen wenn putin denkt
dass er die ukraine ganz leicht erobern
wird dann irrt er sich viel wasser zu
einem langen schrecklichen [ __ ] und so
ist es auch geschehen und die ganze welt
bewundert heute die heldenhaft ich kite
der ukraine die mit großer
entschlossenheit ihrer heimat verteidige
bauteams wir sprachen über ihre
unterstützung und sie sprachen über ihre
besuche in kiew sie waren schon zweimal
dort viele menschen analysten und
politiker sagen dass polen und sie als
präsident die führung übernommen haben
scholz unser kanzler zeigt keine führung
mehr hat kiew noch nicht besucht er wird
dafür kritisiert bei deutschland nicht
genug waffen liefert würden sie
zustimmen dass polen die führung zeigt
wie man bei deutschland vermisst
ich möchte die staatsoberhäupter nicht
beurteilen und ihre entscheidungen aktiv
zu fahren nicht hin zu fahren es gibt
verschiedene umstände verschiedene
ratschläge verschiedener
persönlichkeiten meine persönlichkeit
ist so dass ich der meinung war dass die
unterstützung eine persönliche
unterstützung für die ukraine durch
persönliche anwesenheit wichtig es ist
habe war ich da einige stunden vor der
russischen aggression dort ich hatte
keine angst ich war auch mitte april
während der russischen invasion dortmund
vor kurzem schon zum zweiten mal während
des krieges eigentlich zum dritten mal
in dieser zeit um unter anderem im
ukrainischen parlament
aufzutreten aber ich sage freuen dass
wir polen verstehen die situation sehr
gut wir sind auch entschieden wir
interessieren uns für kleinere geschäfte
mit russland im aspekt der freiheit der
unabhängigkeit souveränität und dessen
dass der russische imperialismus und
potenziell bedroht da gibt es gar keine
diskussion in polen keine würde so eine
diskussion überhaupt aufnehmen keiner
wird ein wort sagen über irgendwelche
geschäfte mit russland in eine situation
wo wir dadurch bedroht sind dass hier
die russische armee herkommen kann sich
weiterhin in der russischen einflusszone
sein könnten und ein russischer
festlegung hier weiß jeder dass
russische festlegung ist es ist tot
erschießung
erschießungen in den hinterkopf sowie
die russen das 1940 in katyn gemacht
haben mit unseren offizieren und unsere
intelligenz ja dass in der rotation nach
sibirien zu schlimmen arbeit von der die
meisten menschen nicht mehr zurückkehren
das ist für uns ganz klar wir wissen
also sehr wohl was eine potenzielle
russische okkupation und invasion sind
weshalb unterliegt es für uns in polen
keinen zweifel dass wir alles
unternehmen müssen um möchte nicht zu
allen russischen invasion kommen zu
lassen und wir müssen eine solche mit
der kraft in polen aufbauen dass wir
binden wird sich bis zum letzten uns
verteidigen können falls sich
herausstellt dass wir angegriffen werden
und wir müssen alle möglichen bündnisse
aufbauen um diese diesen russischen
angriff zu verhindern naja deutschland
schaut sich das von einem anderen
standpunkt aus an und machte große
geschäfte mit russland was mir sehr gut
aber schon nach 2014 hatte deutschland
wenn wir noch lücken in der
eu-gesetzgebung benutzt und seine
produkte von höchster klasse nach
russland geliefert die man zweifach
nutzen konnten auch militärisch und
militärisch de facto russland und dass
putin regime unterstützt haben und heute
ist wie wir hören ein großteil der
deutschen wirtschaft die zu den
stärksten in die welt gehört die wollen
weiterhin geschäfte machen in russland
dem kontext kann man sagen der eindruck
ist für euch entschuldigen sie bitte
vielleicht werden sich einige beleidigt
fühlen dass es diesen teil der deutschen
wirtschaft egal ist was mit der ukraine
was mit polens wir wollen geschäfte
machen russland hat rohstoffe
möglichkeiten wir wollen ein großes land
wir wollen da unsere produkte verkaufen
wir wollen wirklich gas kaufen und erdöl
und so weiter und so fort vielleicht
glaubt die deutsche wirtschaft nicht
daran dass die russische armee jemals
wieder seit ihrem sieg in berlin feiern
könnte und deutschland wieder besetzen
könnte aber wir in polen wissen dass das
möglich ist deshalb gibt es für uns kein
business as usual und deshalb rufen wir
die ganzen welt und ganz europa dazu auf
dass es kein business as usual mit
russland gibt
kanzler in riga ring weapons of life
from germany kann man dafür nur die
industrie beschuldigen es gibt viel
kritik an unserem kanzler und den
deutschen waffenlieferungen sind die
deutschen daran schuld sein die ukraine
den krieg verlieren weil sie zu wenig
waffen liefern
ja absolut ich appelliere an alle um
unterstützung für die ukraine jede form
finanzielle humanitäre unterstützung in
dem sinne dass man transporte mit
humanitäre hilfe für die ukraine
hinschicken appelliere auch darum dass
die ukraine militärisch unterstützt wird
sie brauchen heute schwere waffen
schwerer als die sie brauchen
raketenabwehr waffen sie braucht
panzerfahrzeuge und auch ganze das in
die laufenden bedürfnisse der ukraine
ich habe vor zwei tagen mit präsident
wladimir selensky gesprochen er hat
diese bitten erneut ausgesprochen wir
haben sowohl panzer hingeschickt wir
haben praktisch
zweikampf gruppen von panzern geschickt
über 240 panzer die wir von polen die
ukraine geschickt haben dass ein panzer
die die ukrainische armee auch bedienen
kann das in postsowjetische partie will
in unsere armee zur verfügung hatten
über 100 panzer fahrzeuge haben wir auch
hin geschickt auch verschiedene waffen
angefangen von handwaffen also zum
individuellen gebrauch von gewehren über
große mengen von munition auch über
raketen und wir schickten ende und die
ukraine waffen im wert von fast zwei
milliarden dollar für uns in das enorme
summen aber wie gesagt wir verstehen
dieses bedürfnis
hervorragend und wir wissen dass die
ukraine unterstützt werden sollte und
operieren an alle darum weil jemand nur
die möglichkeit hat
nach in die ukraine waffen zu liefern
artillerie und langstrecken waffen und
raketenabwehr zu schicken das ist für
die ukraine ganz wichtig um die
russische armee anzuhalten und sich zu
verteidigen vor der invasion
so
oder shows
gewisse olaf scholz sagte während des
besuchs in litauen niemand unterstützt
die ukraine ähnlich stark wie
deutschland tut deutschland mehr als
boni
so
vielleicht ich weiß es nicht wenn der
bundeskanzler das gesagt hat dann ist er
offenbar der meinung mutter hat die
entsprechenden daten dafür ich
appelliere darum zu helfen und ich bin
der meinung das ist eine sehr wichtige
sache ist dass diese unterstützung
seitens der internetgemeinschaft kommt
jeder der schwere waffen in die ukraine
schicken kann der pakete hat energie und
glauben sie was er sagt es kommt so viel
kritik aus der ukraine auch von
osteuropäischen staaten dass es nicht
genug unterstützung diesmal leopard
sollte deutschland direkt liefern
redakteur ich möchte jetzt nicht die
wahrhaftigkeit der worte des
bundeskanzlers beurteilen hier das
können die deutschen politiker wird
prüfen die deutschen medien durch zugang
zu öffentlichen informationen zu
entsprechen durch entsprechendes
vorgehen an ort und stelle
deutschland in diesem ausmaß tatsächlich
der ukraine helfen dann kann ich so
sagen als direkter nachbar der ukraine
bin ich dankbar dafür wenn die
unterstützung der ukraine ist jetzt
wirklich notwendig und dann braucht
sowohl humanitäre unterstützung als auch
militärische gesagt die ukraine braucht
heute vor allem schwere waffen schwerer
artillerie
sich der schweren artillerie da rufen
gegen zu setzen die heute die russische
offensive in der ukraine unterstützt und
dann der russland heute weitere orte
einnimmt und ukrainische positionen
zerstört aus großer entfernung also eine
antwort im sinne der schweren artillerie
und lang lira ist das einzige
gegenmittel gegen die offensive ist
der sogenannte ringtausch aus ihrer
sicht eine verzögerungstaktik
ich möchte es noch mal wiederholen die
ukraine braucht unterstützung wir
rechnen heute auch damit dass sie für
diese unterstützung bekommen wie gesagt
wir haben von polen aus ein großteil
unserer bewaffnung aus dem auflaufen
bewaffnung unserer armee dorthin
geschickt das war ja nicht wo in lagern
unter gestellt sondern das waren die
waffen die zur ausstattung unserer armee
gehören diese panzerfahrzeuge und wir
rechnen damit dass wir unterstützung
bekommen von unseren business partnern
in der nato von den vereinigten staaten
da gibt es das programm lend lease ein
altes amerikanisches gesetz auf der zeit
des zweiten weltkriegs das ist im
kongress wieder auf den tisch gekommen
und wurde erneuert wofür ich wofür wir
präsent beiden sehr dankbar sein sollte
auch für die ukraine aber auch für
diejenigen die der ukraine helfen wir
möchten auch im rahmen dieses land liest
auch benutzt es gar kein neues gerät auf
den vereinigten staaten bekommen keine
erwartet und das wollte ich ganz stark
unterstreichen keiner erwartet die
modernsten geräte dabei denn wir haben
ja der ukraine auch keine modernsten
geräte weitergegeben sondern solche die
dort schnell genutzt werden wollen wir
warten also auch nicht auf modernstes
gerät aber wir möchten an stelle dessen
was wir gegeben haben etwas bekommen
jetzt soll in diesem jahr sogar
jurisic usage and government aber sie
haben der deutschen regierung und
zusammenhang mit der lieferung deutscher
waffen wortbruch vorgeworfen
welches versprechen hat berlin genau
gebrochen und wurde das problem gelöst
redakteur ich habe niemanden beschuldigt
ich wohne nur gefragt von einem
journalisten der welt glaube ich in
davos was ich darüber denke dass die
deutschen keine panzer liefern die es
polen versprochen hat ich weiß dass in
deutschland das programm angenommen
worden und ist dass man waffen liefert
für waffen die an die ukraine geliefert
worden sind zum beispiel ich weiß dass
es da dass beide tschechischen armee
geschieht und wir haben damit gerechnet
dass sie waffen auch nach polen geführt
werden und es ist nicht wahr was zum
beispiel im spiegel geschrieben wurde
dass wir die
moderne leopard panzer erwarten das ist
nicht wahr für uns ist es offensichtlich
dass wir an stelle von gar keine
modernen sind alten in der sowjetunion
produziert sind panzer von den über 240
an die ukraine weiter geliefert haben
einige leopard-panzer bekommen wollten
also gar nicht die modernsten denn wir
haben ältere versionen der leopard
panzer in pulp wir wollten dankte hilfe
unsere bewaffnung ergänzen es gibt eine
ältere version ich glaube
24 ich glaube die neueste version ist 2
und wir würden gerne die ältere version
annehmen und dann vielleicht später auch
modernisieren auch mit unterstützung der
deutschen waffenindustrie wurden gern
dafür bezahlen aber wir rechnen damit
dass wir
panzer in der älteren version bekommen
wir haben nichts bekommen so weit ich
weiß nichts ist zwischen davos und heute
passiert hat die deutsche regierung
reagiert haben sie etwas erhalten
ich weiß nichts darüber
dass wir von der deutschen seite
unterstützung bekommen hätten wenn es um
sie warten noch immer ja natürlich
denn wir haben unsere panzer weg gegeben
und jetzt häuser haben bin ich an ihrer
stelle wir führen gerade gespräche
panzer wir haben ein vertrag mit den usa
über 250 moderne abrams panzer
unterschrieben jetzt war unsere
verteidigungsministers tag in südkorea
denn er hat sich mit mir verständlich
und ist dort hingefahren um leichtere
panzer koreanische produktion zu kaufen
auch mehrere hunde für unsere armee
werden wir wollen generell unsere
ausstattung mit modernen panzern
ergänzen aber das ist eine frage von
mehreren jahren bevor die produktion
losgeht und zu uns zukommt wenn wir
heute eine kleine party von deutschen
panzern bekommen könnten der älteren
version um laufend unsere sicherheit zu
stärken und unsere verteilungs potenzial
wären wir da sehr dankbar
bevor der kanzler die lieferung schwerer
waffen ankündigte warnte er in einem
interview vor einem möglichen atomkrieg
er hat noch immer angst davor teilen sie
seine befürchtung
ich würde folgendes sagen wenn wir angst
haben vor den russischen atomwaffen
sollten wir uns alle gleiche geben denn
wenn von den putin raus kommt und sagt
wir jetzt hier die atombomben verstreuen
oder nuklearwaffen gegen europäische
hauptstädte richten wenn ihr nicht brav
seit und dessen plötzlich erlaubt die
russischen zone bis zum atlantik
auszuweiten oder nach lissabon was
sollen wir dann alle angst haben und
sagen ja wir sind einverstanden und wir
werden die richtlinien von hand putin
realisieren und der russische politik
sind ganz europa und wir angst haben
dass eine atombombe auf uns geworfen
wird ich möchte dann hören das nukleare
potenzial der welt und den nato würde
russland zu malen falls es benutzt
werden sollte ist natürlich eine
katastrophe für die welt aber russland
weist das ja auch und putin weiß es auch
und ich bin der meinung wenn irgend
jemand angst hat vor russischen rettung
dann bringt er uns zur katastrophe man
darf vor der russischen erpressung keine
angst da wo heute kämpft russland mit
konventionellen waffen und die
ukrainische armee wie viel kleiner ist
und schlechter ausgestattet ist imstande
ihr die stirn zu bieten und sie stellt
raten widerstand und da ist zeigt dass
man den russischen imperialismus
anhalten kann und dass man keine angst
vor den bedrohungen haben darf in
russland wird das mit allen
verschiedenen arten versuchen um zu
erreichen was ist was ist wilden wirken
das russische fuß wenn sie die tür einen
spalt breit auf 1017 fuß reiten und
werden es immer mehr aushalten und immer
mehr mitnehmen das ist das was ich ja
lang meinen kolleginnen kollegen aus
europa und den usa wird habe russlands
ist kein normales demokratisches land
russische firmen sind keine firmen die
nacht macht und sich den prinzipien
arbeiten so wie sie das verstehen
gazprom ist einfach eine große firma
gazprom ein bewaffneter arm russland ein
werkzeug des russischen imperialismus
gazprom zieht keine dollar oder euro sie
gast kommt überlegt nicht werden ein
befehl vom kreml kommt dann denkt man
nicht darüber nach lohnt er sich teuer
lohnt sich nicht dass dann wird die
strategie der russischen regierung
realisieren
wenn wir über diese atom drohungen
sprechen glauben sie dass die deutschen
allgemein und olaf scholz zu ängstlich
sind
ich würde dir folgendes sagen ich bin
erstaunt über all diese gespräche
weitergeführt werden
mit putin gerade von kanzler
von präsident manual markt kommt diese
gespräche bringen gar nichts aber was
bewirken sie bewirken so eine art
legitimierung du eines menschen der
verantwortlich für verbrechen die von
der russischen armee keine begangen
werden er ist verantwortlich dafür er
hat die entscheidung getroffen die haben
wir dorthin zu schicken ihm unterstehen
die befehlshaber wladimir putin und
während des zweiten weltkriegs auf diese
weise mit adolf hitler gesprochen sagt
jemand dass er sein gesicht bewahren
muss dass man das so machen müsse dass
es für ihn nicht erniedrigt als vater
fiddler solche stimmen hat
der hat einfach polen überfallen
ein großteil europa dann die
große und alle wussten dass er
und besiegt
schulz argument
das argument von scholz und macao ist
dass es nur eine verhandlungslösung
geben kann nur wenn wir reden kann es
eine lösung geben wie kann dieser krieg
aus ihrer sicht enden und wann könnte
nach meiner überzeugung ist es so
dass ist nicht dazu kommen kann eine
verständigung über den köpfen unserer
ukrainischen regierung zu machen es darf
keine verstärkung kommen mit der ukraine
nicht einverstanden seien über die
ukraine muss entscheiden über ihre
angelegenheit die ukraine wurde
überfallen ohne einen rationellen
ehrlichen grund von russland ohne eine
rationale begründung erzählung von
faschisten rheine für das über
ukrainische
nazis das ist einfach blödsinn
vollkommener unsinn das ist russische
propaganda im schlimmsten politischen
stil das ist einfach die komplette rund
wahrheit und natürlich werden die
russischen medien
ihre bevölkerung ein rätsel und werden
versuchen diese lügen in der welt zu
verbreiten aber jede der gut kennen und
die ukraine vor dem krieg kann weil das
ist eine einzige große lüge ist weshalb
gibt es heute gar keine der gründer team
muss eingehalten werden um jeden preis
aber es anhalten von putin muss auf eine
weise stattfinden
akzeptiert wird ich sehe keinen anderen
weg wir können endlich zwar eine
situation wo ring dass jemand versucht
darüber zu entscheiden dass die lokalen
irgendwelche gebiete abgeben soll ohne
dass sie ihr einverständnis dazu gibt
wie kann aus ihrer sicht und das ist
eine diskussion die wir in allen
europäischen ländern sehen dieser krieg
gestoppt werden was wäre ihre lösung
ich wäre am meisten daran interessiert
dass die ukrainische verteidigung eine
solche unterstützung bekommen dass sie
die rosten aus ihrem territorium von
meinem polnischen standpunkt aus gesehen
aber auch vom standpunkt der
weltordnung gesehen von dem ganzen
international völkerrechtlich
anerkannten gebiet des ukrainischen
staates alle sehen alle wissen dass von
dem ganz
völkerrechtlich anerkannten gebiet des
ukrainischen staates wir alle wissen wir
dieses gebiet aussieht damit der vorrang
des völkerrechts viele hergestellt wird
und eine ordnung die wir erwarten würden
in europa eingeführt holen 1889 und von
allen anerkannt worden ist und die
russland in letzter zeit und in letzten
dutzend jahren mehrmals gebrochen die
politisch anerkannten völkerrechtlich
anerkannten grenzen der ukraine sollten
wieder hergestellt oder würde nur ein
sturz putins den krieg stoppen die
wirtschaft also bevor ich glaube nicht
daran dass wolle die mir gut hin den
krieg anhalten wird bevor er erfolg
verzeichnet wenn apple ein imperiales
russland ein import aus russland ist ein
ros letztes dem er weitere gebiete
schluckt das ist ein staat der sich
immer weitere staaten unterordnet und du
das bedeutet für ihn sie dann natürlich
fest entschlossen aber wir müssen es so
eine situation bringen wo er sich wird
zurückziehen müssen und das ist heute
die pflichten interessengemeinschaft
deshalb spreche ich von der
unterstützung durch eine einerseits
militärische durch lieferung von waffen
damit die sie brauchen damit junge keine
auf augenhöhe mit der russischen armee
kämpfen können und zweitens
sanktionspolitik ich weiß das ist so
viel kostet für uns polen kostet sie
auch viel wir haben auch die inflation
probleme mit den energiequellen mit
steigen gas und ölpreisen mit steigenden
strompreisen
natürlich betrifft uns dass das betrifft
sogar mehr als die deutsche bevölkerung
weil wir relativ er mal sehen was wir
haben nicht den lebensstandard denen es
in deutschland ist viel teurer aber und
selbstbewusst zu das passiert dass
russland angehalten werden muss sonst
werden wir uns wieder in russische
sklaverei befinden und kein nimmst will
in polen wie der von den russen fest
laufen seien abdullah specials
ministerpräsident zwei letzte frage es
gibt eine große diskussion über die eu
mitgliedschaft der ukraine
auch markus scholz sind ein wenig
zurückhaltend wie schnell sollte die
ukraine eu mitglied werden
nach meiner überzeugung gibt es zwei
lösungen die situation ist ein schwarz
weiß entweder wird die ukraine kämpfen
weil sie das gefühl hat dass der westen
sagt ja ukraine wir sind bereit sich
aufzunehmen ja wir sehen dich als teil
des großen modernen gemeinsam
vereinigten europas eine gemeinschaft
demokratische staaten ist wo die
menschen in ruhe und frieden erleben und
sich wirtschaftlich entwickeln wollen wo
sie zusammen arbeiten wollen befreundet
sein wollen und keine wir glauben da das
derzeit diese gemeinschaft ist oder man
sagt nein kleine du bist nicht teil
unserer gemeinschaft teil irgendeines
fernost kommt uns nicht mehr also wir
verurteilen
russischen einfluss zonen der andere
möglichkeit gibt es nicht entweder
gehört zu unseren krone oder zur
russischen und die ukraine weil wir sind
gehören zur kultur zone europas wir sind
europa und wollen europa sein und wollen
zu europa gehören zum gemeinsamen europa
des gemeinsam ist offen demokratisch das
selbst bestimmen system niemanden
bedingungen diktiert sowie russland
anderen staaten bedingungen diktieren
will das heißt entweder bekommt die
ukrainische kandidatin es gibt ja noch
die kandidaten status heute form kann
die nase stadt das bistum mitgliedschaft
in der eu gibt es einen langen weg und
eine ganze reihe von bedingungen die
erfüllt und realisiert werden müssen im
wesentlichen kann man sagen dass diese
kandidatenstatus ein politisch
symbolischen charakter
damit verbinde sich für die unreinen
keine direkten zu schicken und für die
verbinden sich damit feinde zu sich und
belastungen die aus dem kandidatenstatus
für die eu in die ukraine oder die
ukraine und moldawien bekommen würden es
ist also eine politische entscheidung
von enormer bedeutung für die
unserer großen europäischen gemeinschaft
ja was ist euch gegenüber offen ihr
werdet zur eu gehören sind glauben
zutiefst daran dass ihr es schafft nicht
nur dass ich verteidigt dass ihr alle
reformen mit macht das ob er die
wirtschaft wieder aufbauen man wird die
ukrainische wirtschaft sowie so aufbauen
egal ob
ein kandidat um status haben wird und
wir müssen ihr sowieso beim wiederaufbau
helfen wir werden sowieso gelder aus der
tasche ziehen müssten es um den
wiederaufbau der ukraine unterstützen
das ist auch für alle klar dann soll sie
noch diesen kandidatenstatus bekommt es
soll diesen impuls für die ukrainische
bevölkerung
letzte frage ist gestern sprach angela
merkel zum ersten mal über den krieg sie
sagte mehr oder weniger dass sie keinen
fehler gemacht hat sie sagte ich muss
mich nicht dafür entschuldigen dass
nicht stark genug versucht zu haben wie
viel schuld hat angela merkel an der
aktuellen situation
die frau bundeskanzlerin
merkel ist nicht mehr öffentlich tätig
als bundeskanzlerin und man kann sagen
dass die beurteilung ihrer arbeit heute
eine domäne der historiker ist und so
wird es in den nächsten jahrzehnten sein
dass wenn ich zurück sein die beurteilen
werden wer recht hatte werden nicht wer
was getan hat um dem krieg zu verhindern
und damit es in zukunft keinen großen
krieg gibt ich möchte herr redakteur die
bundeskanzlerin hier nicht beurteilt ich
habe jahrelang darum gebeten während
meiner amtszeit
innerhalb von sieben jahren als die
bundeskanzlerin
bundeskanzlerin war und ich polnische
präsident ich bat darum den bau von nord
stream zwei aufzuhalten ohne erfolg ich
argumentierte unsere sicht unseres teil
des von europa also es war auch die
slowakei mit herrn andré kuska dem
ehemaligen slowakischen präsidenten
haben wir darum appelliert die
investition anzuhalten wir zeiten ist
als beispiel der russischen imperialen
strategie wo das gas die waffe ist es
geht darum europa zu beherrschen den
europäischen gasmarkt zu nominieren um
dann die bedingungen
zu sagen wir sind heute das land in das
russland die gaslieferung gestoppt hat
es hat so dass alle verträge gebrochen
alle prinzipien plötzlich ohne sich an
diese prinzipien zu halten jetzt während
dieses krieges in der ukraine nach dem
angriff auf die ukraine angesichts
unserer entschieden politik der
unterstützung sind keine verlangen die
russen dass wir in rubel für das gas
bezahlen wir sagten wir würden es nicht
machen und dann brachen sie noch massiv
erträge und stoppten die gaslieferung
zum glück stellte sich heraus dass wir
so vorausschauend waren ein lng terminal
vorher zu bauen es uns heute erlauben es
fehlen der gas aus russland zu ersetzen
ich hoffe dass wir bald eine gasleitung
auf norwegen fertigstellen werden das im
herbst auch gas aus norwegen nach polen
fürchten für unsere bedürfnisse
steht aber für mich kann ich sagen die
tatsache dass
bei beendet wurde das war eine große
politische enttäuschung gegenüber der
kanzlerin meinerseits
gleich so hat sie nicht genug auf sie
gehört
das ist mein einziger kommentar was ich
gerade gesagt habe vielen dank herr
präsident für das interview und ihre
sicht auf die aktuelle krise
vielen dank